pues sí el segundo día del juicio en el
caso de la muerte de georg klein ha
testificado donan williams un ex
luchador de artes marciales que
presenció todo lo sucedido él ha dicho
que cuando vio que derecha bien el
expolicía puso la rodilla sobre el
cuello de floyd mientras éste decía que
no podía respirar no tenía ninguna duda
de que se estaba cometiendo un asesinato
durante la vista judicial ha confesado
además que vio un tremendo dolor en los
momentos finales de la vida de george
floyd fue por eso ha dicho que llamó al
911 al número de la policía para
denunciar lo que estaba pasando
el abogado defensor le ha recriminado
porque no hablo con el resto de policías
que estaban ahí y él ha respondido que
si lo hizo pero que su conversación no
fue fructífera en el audio de la llamada
a la policía se escucha el testigo decir
que floyd no se estaba resistiendo al
arresto la defensa sostiene que el ex
agente actuó siguiendo todos los
protocolos de la policía de mineápolis y
sigue sosteniendo que los motivos de su
muerte fueron las drogas y los problemas
de salud de floyd se espera que
continúen los test
a lo largo del día mientras tanto la
población en mineápolis está
profundamente dividida algunos
consideran que después de este juicio
las políticas contra la violencia racial
se van a endurecer mientras otros creen
que el racismo es un mal sistémico del
ser humano y que aún falta mucho por
hacer